Hello everybody.
I'm Andreea Deac,
PhD student at
Mila University
of Montreal. And
today I'm happy
to present a talk
that I think will,
will be interesting
to all problem
solvers among us.
This is called
neural algorithmic
reasoning. And
we'll we'll talk
about how to combine classical
algorithms and
neural networks.
This is, as you might
think already,
there are two well
known approaches
to problem solving,
each with their
own benefits and
drawbacks. So algorithms are
trivially strongly
generalizable.
You can apply
them to different
sized inputs, and they
will still work.
They you can
compose them if you
have different functions,
subroutines.
You can you can use
them together,
change them.
They have
guaranteed correctness
and they are interpretable.
They have interpretable
operations.
We always know what
they're doing.
However, their
inputs must always
match a specific format,
and they're not robust to task
variations. On
the other hand,
the the more recent, go to,
the the neural networks,
they can operate
on raw inputs.
They can generalize
on basic conditions.
So even if,
our inputs are
are not precise,
they will still work.
They can be used
across tasks.
But a a downside
is that before
getting a neural network to
perform well, we
usually require
a lot of data to train them,
to get them to
a good performance.
They are also unreliable when
extrapolating, and they lack
interpretability,
although that's
actively being worked on.
You might notice
that these two
approaches have
attributes that
are complementary,
and what we,
what we might want is to get
the best of both worlds.
So this is what
today's talk is
going to be about.
And I'll start
by talking about
a problem that is,
quite simple.
Most computer science
students meet it,
at some point or another.
So if we have a weighted graph
with a specific source,
node of interest,
and we want to compute all
shortest paths from this node
to the other nodes
in the graph.
We can do this by using some
dynamic programming
algorithm,
for example,
Bellman form being
one of them.
And recently, there,
there was the,
the paper called
neural execution
of graph algorithms, where,
a team of researchers
tried to,
to propose a neural
network that
can achieve the same goal.
So this was a graph
neural network
in particular that was
supervised to on,
intermediate outputs
of the Bellman
Ford algorithm.
So this was this is also known
as trunk supervision of at,
at every step of
the of the iteration.
And you can see then the what
what we the the operation in
the dynamic programming
algorithm,
aligns quite well
with the message
passing update
rule, in a way.
So this observation was,
was something that was,
explored more in, in
a concurrent work,
where where they
they discovered
that graph neural
networks align well,
in general with
dynamic programming
algorithms, not
just Bellman Ford.
And some other,
findings were were
were pointed out.
So, for example,
this strong supervision I was
talking about is
actually quite
important to
a good performance
of the graph neural network in
imitating the algorithm.
We it requires things like,
a different aggregation,
the max aggregation
to perform well,
which aligns,
again with the with
what we know
the dynamic programming
algorithm,
does. More recently,
there's also been
a lot of work
on proposing better
architectures,
for example, for for,
achieving some
computation classic
computational goals,
and the some even more
recent insights,
for example,
linear algorithmic
alignment is highly
beneficial.
And if we learn
multiple algorithms
in a multi tasking way,
this can also improve
performance.
So this is also very useful,
especially if we
want a component
that learns multiple
algorithms,
not just one.
So this led to
a blueprint being
proposed by Velich, Komichi,
and Glanton, in in patterns.
So under the the name
of neural
algorithmic reasoning,
we have this blueprint,
which starts from
from the assumption
that if we have
a task where we
know an algorithm
could be could
be useful to solve this task,
Then we can pretrain
the processor
on some abstract
inputs to learn this,
how to execute this,
how to simulate
this algorithm.
And then we can take this
processor and plug it into our
natural pipeline.
So in the, in the case of
navigation where we're
interested from,
from getting, in getting from
point a to b, c, or d,
we might want to use something
like Bellarmine Fund,
which computes surface path to
see what is the best way to to
get somewhere, to to
do, to to navigate.
So keeping this
blueprint in mind,
you might be wondering,
does this work in practice?
Has this been used in in some
tasks already?
So in this talk,
I'll talk about,
how this was used
in reinforcement
learning. Our our
proposed agent,
Excelvin, was done
in collaboration
with Petar Velish
Velishkovich,
Piotr Bakon, Jan Tang,
and Vlad Nikolic.
And even more recently,
explored this
blueprint was also
explored in a self supervised
learning setup,
in the paper named reasoning
modulated
representations about
which I won't have
time to talk,
but I recommend you
you go check it out.
So to jump straight into it,
in a reinforcement
learning setup,
we have an agent that,
acts upon a word and receives
observations back
from this word.
This agent can decide
to build a plan,
and update this plan based on
observations, a plan that can
then be used on deciding which
actions to take.
So formalizing this a bit,
this is usually found under
the Markov decision
process framework,
where we have a state space,
an action space.
We have transition
the transition
matrix. So what's
the probability
of being,
of getting to a state s frame
given that we're in a current
state s and we take
a specific action a.
Also rewards.
So what's the reward that,
the agent will receive by,
doing action a in state s?
And the goal is to
find the policy,
pi that tells me what what is
the sequence of actions that I
need to take in
order to optimize
the discounted
cumulative reward.
So get,
as much reward over a longer
time horizon as possible.
So policies that act purely
through adapting
to rewards are
called reactive.
And in many cases,
to to get them to work well,
they require a lot of data and
are quite slow to adapt.
And planning is something that
was proposed to
ameliorate these
issues by maintaining
an explicit
model of the world.
So what this means is that we
would have a state transition
model and the reward model,
which would usually train from
some observed trajectory.
So having the agent,
acting to the world and gather
some data. And using
these motors,
a planner can
simulate the effects
of actions before
taking them,
which is very important and
comes with some
important benefits
as as we are going
to see now.
So some of these
benefits well,
the first one is
data efficiency.
And this is very important if
we're planning to
use our agents
in real world where we don't
have access to
millions of frames
as we do in
the case of games.
So if if we have
the good model,
that would mean that we'd have
to interact less
with the environment
in order to get,
a good policy.
Then strong models will also
allow us to adapt to
unseen situations.
So that is very important,
if if anything is changing in
the environment, for example,
And also very important for
safety reasons because if we
have a strong model predicting
if some action would be would
lead to a unsafe outcome,
that that means that we can
avoid taking that that action
to to learn, that
would happen.
So, this would this is quite
important from
a safety considerate.
It will also allow
us to account for,
external factors such as human
interactions. And in fact,
this was already used
in game training,
alpha go, which
you've probably
heard about, and
across the sciences,
for example, for
chemical synthesis.
Planning has some,
theoretical,
results that that are
very encouraging.
So if we had
the perfect model,
this would allow
us to plan for
perfect policies,
and this is quite important.
One algorithm that
is very useful
for planning is
value iteration.
This is a dynamic
programming algorithm,
which is we'll
see why why it's
important in a bit,
that can allow us to perfectly
solve a reinforcement learning
environment. So what
this does is it,
it computes values of states
based on the values
of neighboring
states. And it starts
with, for example,
a random estimate
and gradually
improves this
estimate until it
reaches an optimal solution.
So this is guaranteed
to happen,
which is very convenient.
And if once we complete this
optimal solution,
then the optimal policy can be
found just by
taking the actions
that maximize these values.
So once we now
now that we know
about this very
useful algorithm,
well, we we we could think,
what what can we do with it?
So could we actually use it in
a reinforcement
learning environment?
That would be
a a great thing.
Assuming for now,
we'll assume that
we have the reward
function and
the transition matrix.
And in a bit, we'll talk about
what what to do when we don't
have these two things.
So we assume the transition
matrix is fixed and known.
By known, for example,
each state has no
neighbors, up,
down, left, right.
The actions are
deterministic,
and computing
value doing value
iteration would
amount computing
sums of neighboring values.
And this might already remind
you of something that's
that's familiar.
So convolutional
neural networks
are quite well
suited to computing
this convolution
like, computation.
And this idea was,
leveraged in value
iteration networks,
which got the best paper award
in NeurIPS in twenty sixteen.
So to to summarize,
they assuming the MDP
is discrete,
fixed, and null,
they perform value iteration
computation by stacking,
shared convolutional errors.
And while this is great,
it has the the downside that
this is quite restricted in
the sense the MDP
needs to be discrete,
fixed, and no.
And Givens already
take a step towards,
more general cases
extending to
to the case where the the MDP
doesn't have to be
agreed for it.
But it is still
fixed and known.
So in that case,
like, so far,
we didn't need to
estimate the transition
model. We didn't
need to to find
one that the the p would be,
and we didn't
have to deal with
continuous state
spaces either.
But what would
happen if we did
another mdp?
Well, we can think a bit,
what would the human feature
engineer do to
use validation,
which you've seen with a very
useful algorithm.
So the human feature engineer
would take the game
frame, the,
which we call
the natural input
and compute some
abstract input
from it on which it they would
be able to run
the value iteration
algorithm to get
abstract outputs.
However, we've seen that deep
learning does a very good job
when we don't have to manually
compute features.
So we'll we'll use
some of this,
some of this insight and have
an encoder, that,
bypasses this part of,
human engineering.
So this would stick
our natural input,
to an embedding.
And that is great,
but that that
will still not be
everything we need to run
validation if we didn't have
the transition matrix.
For that, we can use
a transition model,
to build this local MDP that
where we need in order to run
value iteration.
And this was already studied,
quite a bit, and there exist
many popular methods for for
training this
transition model.
I'll just name one of them,
which is what we
used in our in
our proposed agent.
So contrastive learning,
is is one way of training t.
And this would be this would
mean training t
to discriminate
between true next states and
some fake next next states,
some randomly
sampled, s tilde.
So if we have a traditional
model that learned how to how
the next state s primes
will look like,
this transition model then can
then be used in a in
a in a generative
manner in a way to to build
the the tree over which we had
run value iteration.
So if we have this
tree, we have the p,
but we still don't
have the reward
model. So for now,
we'll assume that
this is given.
We'll assume that the nodes in
it in the in the tree I I've
previously shown are no.
And that would
be everything we
need to run value iteration,
directly over this tree.
And this is exactly what was
done in pre q n and value
prediction networks.
And to summarize
their architecture,
we have the state
and the encoder,
which is then,
is then used repeatedly
to build a tree.
And from industry,
the values are
estimated in each
of the nodes,
and then this then this can be
used for value iteration to to
do the backup and
and use this.
So to to summarize a bit what
I've talked about so far,
we mapped our
natural inputs to
the space of abstract inputs
using an encoder.
Using a transition model,
we build a local MDP,
and we estimated
the rewards in
in each of the nodes
in in the case
of GQN.
And this allowed
us to run value
iteration directly
on this tree.
And this is quite convenient
because it aligns
in the direction
of implicit planners.
That is a very
neat direction.
I I recommend you
read more about,
if you're if this sounds,
like something that would be.
However, doing this running
value iteration
directly on this tree,
presents us with
the algorithmic
bottleneck. So real world data
is often incredibly rich,
and we still have
to in the previous
case, we still had to compress
it to scalar values.
So the the value
iteration solver
committed to using the scalar
the model predicted
and assumed
it was perfect.
And if there is insufficient
data to estimate
these scalars,
then the algorithm is running
on incorrect inputs.
So incorrect outputs will very
likely go out.
So this means that we need to
have correct inputs
for the value
iteration to do what we want,
and we hit data efficiency
problems again,
which is precisely
what planning
was supposed to solve.
So trying to avoid
this bottleneck
of the algorithm
gives a perfect
solution but in a suboptimal
environment, we propose our
agent exfiltrim,
which is aimed at
breaking the bottleneck
. And, the main,
idea behind it is that neural
networks derive
great flexibility
from their late
representations.
They are inherently
high dimensional,
which means that
if any part of
that of that high dimensional
vector is predicted poorly,
then the rest of
the vector can
be can be used
to to compensate
and still lead us to
a correct answer.
So to break the bottleneck,
we replace the value
iteration solver,
like, by we we train the value
iteration directly
on the scalars
with the neural network.
So that combination I was,
I was mentioning earlier on.
So what we'll do is we'll have
a neural network
between natural
inputs and abstract inputs in
that encoder, and we'll also
have a neural network between
our abstract inputs
and abstract
output instead of
having the value
iteration algorithm.
How do we do that?
We do it by
pretraining a graph
neural network
to perform value
iteration style computations,
on synthetic graphs.
So something we can
easily generate.
And then we freeze this.
We keep this as a trained
reasoning component and deploy
it within our planner.
And you might
remember as value
iteration is
a dynamic programming
algorithm, this is
quite easy to do,
thanks to this algorithmic
alignment that,
was pointed in in the in the I
clear twenty paper.
So putting all together,
our Excel agent
looks like this.
We have the the state,
our neural network,
encoder taking to a latent
representation, our transition
model that is used
to build that
local MDP that in the case of
value iteration networks
was assumed no,
but now we don't have,
as as we won't
have have in most
of the reinforcement learning
environments we're
looking at.
Then after we
build this tree,
we use our pretrained
executor,
that we pre trained
on synthetic graphs.
And we use this
to predict values
and actions and plug this into
your reinforcement learning
algorithm of choice,
in our case,
BPO. So to look
a bit on the on
the empirical side,
our our agent is in green.
We compare it with HCC,
which is the the the model I
talked about earlier, which,
actually runs value iteration
in scalar space rather than,
in latent space,
as Excel VIN does with our pre
trained executor.
And we also compare
with a component
that, is just model
free, doesn't have,
any planning component.
So we see that usually,
in in a lot of the cases,
the XAV and the ATC do better
than the than
the PPO baseline.
And something
else that is very
interesting to notice
is the Excelfin
does better than HCC,
particularly in the first half
of the training.
So it does well in
low data cases,
which is one of
the main things
why we're looking
at culling in
the first place.
So this is quite
an encouraging result.
To draw some conclusions,
we we looked at we presented
this this blueprint,
that is applicable if we know
a specific algorithm
will be of
interest for
solving a natural,
a real world task.
So we,
we see that real
world solutions
can benefit from
combining classic
algorithms with
neural networks,
and this is one way
of going about it.
Then we build on
the on the findings
that graph neural networks are
particularly well suited to
imitate some algorithms,
in particular
dynamic programming
algorithms. And one example is
backward forward and other is
value iteration.
Value iteration, which is,
a very useful algorithm in
reinforcement learning as it
allows allows us to plan,
and it can lead to
to perfect plans.
And using this,
this component that
learns the immediate
value iteration in a,
in a reinforcement
learning agent,
led us to find that it can,
it can have great benefits.
For example, having
good performance
in low data cases.
Thank you for listening.
Some of this, work was already
presented in in some
some nice articles.
So, do check them out if you
would like to hear to hear see
more about this.
And, of course,
these were presented in in
research papers,
neuroalgosmic
reasoning, again,
neuroalgosmic reasoning
as an inclusive
planners. I'll also link them
here if you'd
like to read more
about them.
Last time, lastly,
but not not least,
I'm happy to take questions.
And in general,
if you if you have thoughts,
feel free to send
me an email.
Thank you.